women judging from bathroom signs
basically men who swallowed a trapezoid
it's been an especially rough few years
in America for women from abortion bans
to the confirmation of a Supreme Court
justice with resting beer face to the
election of a president who thinks of
their genitals as handles although to be
fair to balance it all out women did
also get this you are not seeing things
McDonald's iconic golden arches have
been flipped upside down and turned into
a W for women oh nice coming whoop
Donnell's and really why did you stop
there the golden arches are so versatile
aren't they yes you can flip them upside
down for women but you can also turn
them on their side for eunuchs and turn
them on their other side into a three
for the actual number of rats you needs
to make one McRib I'm not saying that
rats are in the McRib I'm saying they
make them it's disgusting in a different
way but this week this week saw a
historic milestone because Tuesday marks
the 100th anniversary of Congress
passing the 19th amendment which
enshrined in the Constitution woman's
right to vote which is both a long time
and when you think about it not nearly
long enough in an ideal world women
would have been guaranteed the right to
vote for a lot longer than Kirk Douglas
has been breathing but but tonight I
want to focus on a milestone for gender
equality that we haven't actually
achieved yet the Equal Rights Amendment
it's something that's been under
consideration for a while the struggle
for an Equal Rights Amendment traces
back to 1923 when feminists Alice Paul
wrote the words that became er a
equality of rights under the law shall
not be denied or abridged by the United
States or any State on account of sex
and that's basically it the core of the
Equal Rights Amendment is just 24 words
long and the idea behind it is broadly
popular in fact according to advocates
80 percent of us think it's already in
the Constitution it's one of those
things that's so obvious you assume we
already have it it's like when you see
baking soda at the store you think I
don't need to buy baking soda I
definitely already have baking soda
it's a staple and then you get home and
you're baking a cake and you're reaching
in the cupboard for baking soda and you
realize woman's still aren't
guaranteed equal rights under the
Constitution and there was actually a
time when the ER a had a lot of momentum
it sailed through Congress in 1972 with
84 senators voting for it despite a few
of their colleagues objections male
opponents in the Senate called it the
unisex amendment they said it would
destroy traditional man-woman
relationships the Senate wasn't swayed
and tonight after a 49 years struggle a
constitutional amendment appears on the
way proclaiming once and for all that
women have all the same rights as that
other sex weight that of the sexes that
sounds like what you say when you've
somehow forgotten the word men women
have the same rights as what are they
called her swollen boys two-legged
horses with jobs shaved bears who
thought someone help me here please
having parked the House and the Senate
the only remaining obstacle was per 38
states to ratify it and that is where
the holdup has been we never quite
crossed that threshold although we are
tantalisingly close 37 states have
ratified it over the years so we just
won away and if you live in one of the
states that's holding out that can be
pretty dispiriting as these Florida
residents found out Florida is one of
the holdouts oh my god
courcelette I love living in Florida
nothing makes sense there the laws the
alligators not even the weather everyone
in that clip is dressed for an entirely
different season mid May late October
and September 13th 1992 the fact is
though we have never been closer to the
ER a being enshrined in our Constitution
and just six weeks ago there were even
hearings in Congress on this very
subject so tonight we thought it might
be a good time to ask why is it taking
so long to pass the ER a what would it
mean if we did and how can we finally
get it done and let's start from the
beginning when Congress passed the ER a
many saw it as part of an overall
movement towards justice as one
supporter expressed at the time albeit
in less than ideal terms this is equal
rights for all people of every sex every
color every race I don't care if they're
homos or what Wow that speech was a real
roller coaster so inspirational only to
fall at the last second and it's
becoming that Martin Luther King arguing
children should be judged not by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character even the dirty
Catholics Oh dr. King you really could
have done without that last bit the er8
was passed with a deadline of 1979 to
get the 38 states needed and that
initially seemed like it was gonna be no
problem it was endorsed by Democrats and
Republicans including President Nixon
and within a year 30 states had ratified
it Hawaii did so just 32 minutes after
Congress approved it that's unbelievably
fast especially considering that
according to whole pig roast calm it can
take Hawaiians 12 hours just to roast a
pig which is in and of itself ridiculous
I can roast a pig in just four seconds
I'll show you hey Pig your mom
pigs put an apple in your mouth
you've been run
yes you big pig but all that momentum
came to a crashing halt which many
historians credit to just one woman
Phyllis Schlafly
if you've never heard of her
congratulations but she founded a group
called stop er a and she was all over
the media in the 70s spreading fear
about the ER a some of what she argued
it would do like lead to women being
included in the military draft was
absolutely possible but a lot was
like claiming it would outlaw
sex segregated bathrooms and then there
was also this nonsense under our system
in case of the breakup of marriage the
mother gets her children in most cases
now who wants to trade that in for a
so-called equality whereby each parent
gets one child well I think the Equal
Rights Amendment says in case of a
divorce each parent gets one it says
that you've got to interpret things
absolutely equally that's right that's
right now if one of the children is
better than the other one the Equal
Rights Amendment says you have to cut
off a little bit of the first one and
give it to the second one because
everything's got to be exactly equal
from now on so you've got to give your
son his sister's big toe the e ra says
that that's a fact now obviously that is
not what equal rights means it's not
that everything has to end up exactly
equal it's just the law cannot
disadvantage you based on gender but
that didn't masa de Schlafly she was
basically a pre-internet internet troll
gleefully greeting audiences with lines
like this I would like to thank my
husband Fred for letting me come today I
love to say that because it irritates
the women's libbers more than anything
that I say okay that thank you to fred
is entirely unnecessary for two reasons
one wives are not property of their
husbands and two I'm not sure how big a
sacrifice it was for Fred to spend a few
hours
hanging out with Phyllis Schlafly in
fact a guest peg was absolutely okay
with Phyllis getting out of the house
for the day the night even I mean where
is this rally if it's more than 10
minutes away might make sense just to
stay over and if it's any later than in
the week that's a Wednesday just say
that weekend Phyllis no thank you
necessary don't even mention it or
anything else to Fred ever again
sloth Lea became a major player in the
rise of the religious right rallying
conservatives to oppose the e ra and one
of the most galvanizing tentpoles of
their argument was that the e ra would
expand access to abortion in fact when
three first ladies came together at a
pro er a Women's Conference slackly
organized a protest rally featuring this
ferocious speech from a Republican
congressman and the greatest tragedy of
all was to see three former first ladies
of this nation approving of sexual
perversion and the murder of young
people in their mother's world okay so
that was a lot and first the e ra
doesn't say anything about abortion or
any other policy all it says is that men
and women have to be treated equally
under the law
and second if your view on abortion
requires that men and women not be
explicitly equal you may want to rethink
your view on abortion if someone stood
up at a city council meeting and said
passing this law against animal torture
would make it impossible to run my pizza
parlor then holy their pizza parlor
never should have existed in the
first place and yet thanks to arguments
like those the e ra had become so toxic
that by the 1979 deadline only 35 states
had ratified it and even though Congress
then extended the deadline by three
years not a single additional state
signed on and look I'm not saying that
there are not laws on the books out
lawyering gender discrimination there
are and if you're then wondering well
hold on if that's the case why do we
still need the e ra it's because laws
can be rolled back by a simple act of
Congress and policy guidelines can go
away based on who's in charge that is
happening right now Congress recently
let the Violence Against Women Act
expire and the Trump administration has
rescinded
more than 20 policy cut lines on title 9
anti-discrimination laws a
constitutional amendment like the e ra
is more stable because constitutional
amendments are safe from Donald Trump
unlike milania's hopes and dreams and
any American flag he gets close to
constitutional amendment to something he
cannot easily ruin now some would argue
that women do have protection under the
Constitution specifically the 14th
amendment which guarantees individuals
equal protections under the law since
the 1970s the Supreme Court has
interpreted that to cover gender
discrimination but not everyone agrees
that it should be interpreted that way
in fact one of those people former
Justice Antonin Scalia
once straight-out said the 14th
amendment does not cover discrimination
by gender at all certainly if the
Constitution does not require sexual
discrimination discrimination on the
basis of sex the only issue is whether
it prohibits it it doesn't nobody ever
thought that that's what it nobody ever
voted for that yeah he's right of course
if women wanted that amendment to cover
gender discrimination they should have
voted for it in 1868 why didn't they do
that silly ladies look Scalia was a
die-hard originalist and as insane as I
personally find his philosophy of ruling
on cases by jumping inside the long-dead
brains of history's various misogynist
and racists there are a lot of people
who think that way and Trump has
promised to put more of them on the
bench saying he wants justices very much
in the mold of Justice Scalia which I
can only hope means dead but I worry
might mean interpreting the Constitution
without protections for gender and that
is where the ER a would come in
you can't interpret it as not addressing
gender discrimination because that's all
it addresses and that brings us to our
final question how can we finally after
all these years make the ER a part of
our Constitution because it is very much
possible yes the deadline passed in 1982
but legal scholars believe that Congress
could simply change the deadline again
or eliminate it entirely in fact bills
to do that have been introduced in both
the House and the Senate
just this year with bipartisan
co-sponsors meanwhile states have been
moving the er a forward with Nevada and
Illinois both ratifying it in the last
couple of years and for State Senator
Pat Spearman who was behind Nevada's
ratification push the reasons for doing
so were all too clear people who are
born in privilege always debate whether
or not those of us who were not deserve
equality and so what we're talking about
here what we are talking about here is
the fact that equality is not available
we are born with it the only thing we're
asking in the ER a is to acknowledge the
fact that women are born equal to men
she's right
none of this is that complicated
equality for women should be a basic
principle of our society and if you
think it already is great all the more
reason to write it down and if you think
it isn't then we badly need the ER a-and
look I'm not saying that it will fix
everything not by a long shot for one
thing it focuses on discrimination by
the government not the private sector so
for an issue like closing the wage gap
most women would have to continue to
rely on other legislation and of course
stealing from their male co-workers
hashtag feminism hashtag lady fingers
but but the ER a could at the very least
be a safeguard against things sliding
further backwards and we are just one
state away giving these thirteen states
a huge opportunity to genuinely make
history and one Arizona Legislature is
inspired by what this could mean if we
do this this goes down in the history
books
Arizona goes down in the history books
exactly she's right about that Arizona
could go down in the history books and
let's be honest here that just doesn't
happen much the most famous part of
Arizona is the Grand Canyon you know the
part of Arizona where there's notably
less of Arizona anywhere else there'd be
more Arizona there but instead there's
just this sudden lack of Arizona
it's everyone's favorite part the point
here is any of these 13 states have a
huge chance to change how history views
them forever so the only real question
here is which one of you wants to seize
that chance which state is going to take
this opportunity to put this amendment
over the top and write themselves into
the history books
will it be Arizona or Georgia or could
it be you Oklahoma you could be known
for something other than tornadoes and
musicals about how great mourning is
which it isn't by the way it never is
it's just like nights but unpleasantly
brighter could it be one of the
Carolinas could it be you Utah or you
Missouri you could be famous for making
history rather than having a state flag
there's just two bears your
Christmas ornaments what could it be in
Florida or Mississippi maybe you could
holy Mississippi I always forget
that's on your flag so Mississippi
the actual is that I mean yeah you
could party all right but let's be
honest it will be extremely out of
character Louisiana it could be you
Arkansas it could be you Alabama it
definitely won't be you but Virginia it
really could be you plus you are the
birthplace of Chris Brown Rick Santorum
and Pat Robertson so frankly you
owe America this any one of these
thirteen states has a huge opportunity
that's taking this country almost a
hundred years to make it's not every
time you get a chance like this and all
I can say is somebody please do it
before Florida because I do not want to
give them credit for this
you